grabbing the attention of the Prime
Minister or trying to these Belfast
shipyard workers are set to lose their
jobs their predicament just one of the
challenges Northern Ireland's devolved
government here at Stormont could be
addressing if it were up and running
Boris Johnson promised to spare no
effort to make that happen government
without storm on for two years and six
months so my prime focus this morning is
to do everything I can to help
get up and running again the five
political parties here have been talking
since May about how to get the Northern
Irish Assembly back in business it was
set up in 1998 as part of a peace deal
that gave this part of the UK a degree
of autonomy but issues including Irish
language rights and access to abortion
remain divisive on top of that
politicians have wildly differing views
on brexit and specifically Boris
Johnson's insistence that the EU scraps
the so called Irish backstop keeping the
whole of the UK closely aligned with EU
rules until there's a trade deal in
place it is very clear that it is the
backstop that has caused all of the
difficulties were so after all agreement
and therefore that needs to be the
subject of focus negotiations to deal
with it and therefore we will support
the Prime Minister in New England other
parties say the backstop is essential to
prevent a hard border they're worried
what they call the Prime Minister's
hardline strategy will backfire and see
the UK leave the EU without a deal that
in their view would inevitably lead to
physical checks at the border between
Northern Ireland and the Republic of
Ireland and for shin Fame the main
nationalist party it could even mean a
push for a referendum on uniting north
and south we've made it clear to him
that the extents of planning that he
tells us he is carrying out in respect
of a potential crash breaks that has to
include the constitutional question and
the issue of a border pole here in
Ireland
Sinn Fein's ultimate aim is and always
has been achieving a united Ireland and
their clear warning to the prime
minister is the way he's going about
brexit could make that prospect a great
deal more likely for now
the action at Stormont is outside the
Parliament not inside even if the
Assembly does against all expectations
resume its work in the near future the
challenge of protecting the Good Friday
Agreement that created it could make
delivering any kind of brexit an uphill
struggle nadine barber al jazeera
Belfast